it was recently announced nick that
ariana is now coming she's going to take
your seat next season so here's the
reason why i asked what
do you have wait a minute exactly wait
exactly
it's just this season so like here's my
question though do you have any advice
for her
uh no i mean ariana as we all know is
one of the best
singers in the game and she's gonna be
an incredible coach
uh i i think the only advice i would
give is just not to trust
any one of you
[Laughter]
we've been feeding her lots of useful
advice yeah i'm sure
very useful yes yeah uh but she's gonna
kill it she'll be great
yeah um i thought yeah you could at
least warn her about the one she's
probably gonna sit next to
might be nice all of you she watches the
show though she knows
she knows about blake she does watch the
show she knows
everybody about blake yeah everybody
knows
lies and deception i just hope i don't
step on her
are you look at her she looks so tiny on
there she's so tiny
the height differential between the two
of you will be substantial wow
i really hope she's sitting right next
to you it'll just look amazing
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure